thank you good morning members welcome
to this meeting the standards committee
and i'd also like to welcome anybody
watching on youtube
do we have any uh apologies
please
we've had apologies from cancer in each
chair thank you very much thank you
that brings us to the uh the minutes
does anybody have any matters they wish
to raise on the
[Music]
follow the discussion regarding dna's
checks and independent members and
counselors
and legal and governments and launchers
have confirmed the dps not mandatory
councils right
all i could understand was in
2018 full council wanted
to bring dds checks into the
constitution
by 20 odd votes
and that doesn't seem to happen
and one question here is why we have i
think less than about 60 percent of our
councils dbs checked and yet devon
county council had a virtual hundred
percent
um
i wrote to
john mart and phil murray and asked why
the discrepancy why it was that
demonstrated cancer because cancer
cancers would be
happening dbf checks
and
tolerance are not in the constitution
surely with the same rules and the fire
had was i think again like 2017 2018
that prestigious committee voted to
bring dbs checks in
standard the years checks and if someone
was found with a legal advisor
now my question really is
since one council voted
by a large majority of the written dds
checked in
what happened that was in august 2018
right thank you for your question stacey
do you have an update on that at all
yeah i think um the difficulty that
we've got so it wasn't the constitution
that members must have dbs checks
um and then it was discussed again when
we had the constitution working group
um but from our officers perspective
although we would obviously encourage
all councillors to have dps checks we
can't force you to do it
um and that's the difficulty so making
it um
as a rule which it was previously is
fine but the difficulty that we have is
there's no sanctions
um for not having that check so that was
again discussed by members and it was
decided that if members had had a dbs
check we would put that on the internet
on our website and if they haven't had a
dps check it would remain
blank
um so to have a dps check we offer it to
all councillors obviously at the time
that they're
elected you've got to bring in two forms
of id to the hr department and then
we'll do this checks for you but it's
physically
making members do that and i have no
power
and actually there are no sanctions
should you not have one but why do with
coming back
why is it the county cancers all seem to
fall over themselves because my thought
was well maybe it's a case of if you
have another object you don't want to
commit
you know that was one way of sort of not
forcing them to do it but if you want to
commit or something made men or whatever
you don't know check their position
yet if you look at the
county's website
there's i think 100 compliance by about
four or five but i still can't maybe
have an update i can't see the
difference between
county
and
district this is i understand the
difficulties of making people do this
but
having voted for it
we don't seem to move any further
forward and yet they had a committed
2017 2018 that again voted like this was
the same
thing that's gone through and everybody
seems quite happy
i understand the difficulties
yes well maybe seeing the town
[Music]
it actually says meet the children
how embarrassing would be
if a counselor is meeting children and
their parents will be all dvs
checkpointing
or not and that would be embarrassing to
pay for that counselor possibly
for the council
that's the difficult thing and i do
appreciate the fact that selected
members is
and they had no legislation before 2017
2018
and
we don't
i sense your frustration but if it's not
mandatory
[Music]
can i just come back and i think members
of important pay in this because you
know you just mentioned um
you know maybe not being put on
committees and obviously it's not
officers who decide he goes on
committees and that's that's so but i i
think you know members between
themselves should encourage members
because as an officer
i have no sanctions to put in play that
i can put in place you know once you're
elected as as we we all know um with the
standards regime
um
there's very little that we we can do
but i i do agree
from a public perspective and the fact
that councillors are in a position of
authority and responsibility that dbs
checks
um should be undertaken but
the government would need to legislate
for that
um ultimately um
and
you know if they haven't had a dps check
i can't do anything about that although
you know from our perspective we
would always actively encourage and
obviously we'll very happily do those
checks as well um and at any time during
um being a member you can come forward
and we'll do those checks and then we'll
update the website but
other than that i think members need to
put pressure on members
i'm fine
finally i'm quite happy to send you the
link and it says the link i've had for
them to cancel
with us
thank you for your contribution i can
feel your passion for it
counselor james said
thank you chair i'm not part of the
committee um
but i'm meeting with the council and i'm
also dps checked i would encourage all
members to do it the slight difference
between the district and the county is
the county responsible for adult and
children care and for any county council
to be involved in that they do have to
be dbs check so i think
that they tend to order it so that it
doesn't limit their options on which
committees and that they serve whereas
we do not whilst we do mix with children
and i do work with the youth sector and
so i am doing this check um it is not
part of the function of this council to
work with and almost not directly with
adults and children care so that is the
side difference i understand
thank you very much
that clarifies a couple of points
i did raise this question some months
ago innovative
and kirsty fully explained the reason
why
it's not mandatory requirements and now
to ask
members to voluntarily ask
to have a dds check
and if subsequently something then came
up
it could
[Music]
um
um
just just to add um there has been some
new legislation that's just coming in
relation to sexual offences so there are
certain types of sexual offences that
you can't be convicted of and hold a um
hold your post as counsellor
um even from that perspective i think
tom's updated the election forms
um
and you have to take a box to say
whether you've had one of these
convictions so it's a yes or a no box
um so again
from our perspective
i guess if there was a conviction and
you take the notebooks then that's a
different matter because it's been
legislated for but again we will be
encouraging dbs checks for that
that reason um but
the strange thing with that is you can
have that conviction now
when does that come from
yeah so
pretty
june if you've had that conviction
you can still remain as a counselor if
you get that conviction post the 28th of
june you can't
thank you uh stacy
item three decorations
sorry so
just gonna get it right
[Music]
oh
right okay
item three declarations of interest
members with interest have declared
should refer to the agenda item and
describe the nature of their interest
when the item is being considered
item 4 is
to agree the adjournment between
[Music]
thank you
all right um
urgent matters brought forward i do not
have any
uh right
sanctions uh the process
this is gives us an opportunity to
talk about the sanctions and decide if
we want to make representation to
government to
boston in any way
my view is the sanctions
be god
are good
but
they're not
top levels because they're just
members have any views
to deal with particularly um
abuse of federal members and stuff like
that so
my recommendation that i can't do it to
the committee would be to consider
whether
we did support the lga in their approach
to aids
um
[Music]
[Music]
i wish it wasn't
needed
that there would be enough respect for
standards
[Music]
[Music]
all in favor
[Music]
just explain to the committee because
there has been um as i'm sure you're all
aware has been a review already um by
the government in relation to the
standards regime and the sanctions so i
didn't know that might just
i've probably done it too late now chair
because um we've already had the
proposal the second
and the vote on it but i don't know if
it would help if i just explained and
the recommendations from um the
standards of public life
supports the government and the
government's response to thus say far
um
so one of the recommendations that the
committee made was that the local
government of the congressman should be
given the power to investigate and
decide upon an allegation
and a breach by a counsellor and the
appropriate sanction
um and one of those sanctions um being a
suspension if the local government
ombudsmen need that to be appropriate
um and that subsequently any investment
decisions should be binding on us as a
local authority so
at the moment what the government says
is it's up to the local authority to
have a standards regime however you want
to do that and and obviously
our standards regime should be
robust and i think
our regime
is as robust as it can be at this stage
given the sanctions that we're able to
to
um so we're not told as to how to have
our regime but what we do and what is
legislated for is is the outcomes that
we can
that members can propose
um
the government um felt that
it could prevent free speech um for
members and that you would effectively
be policing what members say if you
allowed an independent
body to intervene
um
and it says on the rare occasions when
there are notable breaches of the code
of conduct
local authorities are not without
sanctions under the current regime
um
and they say that um
members can be barred from being
on
um committees or a member of that that
political group
and and
i think that's partly
part of the problems that we've kind of
had because we're i didn't say it's a
problem but we're an independent
council's reach that all those members
is an independent in their own
own right i respect the government
seeing it from a political point of view
where they've got a lot more
more clout um
so that's effectively what they said um
they did say the government will engage
with sector representatives um bodies of
councillors and officers
to seek news and options to strengthen
the sanctions
um
the breaches but
in any event if it's that bad it's
criminal
activity and it should be reported
to the police as opposed to a local
authority
well let us hope that they
they listen
it's not just us
[Music]
[Music]
on from from that i mean are there any
um specific sanctions that members want
us to make representations on or
just
bearing in mind to what the government's
already said in response to
um
[Music]
[Music]
yeah i guess it's it's
it's what um i mean under our current
sanctions regime you can make any other
recommendations that are
that you feel as a committee are
necessary i guess the difficulty is um
you can't
stop them from undertaking their
counsellor duties um so you've still got
to facilitate
that and access to the offices for
committee meetings and and that and i
think that's been the difficulty
previously in that it's very hard to
impose sanctions
whilst also being aware that they've
been elected as their community by their
community
um and still have to carry out their
counsellor function
just a question should they be allowed
to carry out their counsellor function
if they've been
called up against this committee
then
it's not it's not something minor and i
think i think us as a committee should
have the opportunity
to at least suspend them
from all duties you know
and also there's you know
we don't have
it we just don't have any teeth we can
bring them in and they basically laugh
at it so what are you going to do with
this you know you can't
you have no
you know
i mean
it just seems ridiculous that we can't
say you know keeping to the point that
suspending them completely and saying
you know kicking them out
i mean
if if a situation is that bad and when
we should be in a situation where as a
council and as a spanish committee
we can say look you're not worthy of the
role that you
that you're in
that's the
[Music]
and unfortunately their electorate can't
vote them out
they're looking at us
in the standard i would have thought as
a spanish committee to have the highest
standard
you know i mean just i mean
i'm a conservative
councillor
and what's going on in central
government is is disgusting
you know and we don't need that in in
down to earth if you like we're running
we're trying to run a council
um that's honest and true
is the best way i can describe it
and if somebody comes up against us and
is dishonest and not true we should have
the means
to invite them to lead you know if one
of our officers was dishonest and true
there wouldn't be we wouldn't be having
a question
it would be hr there's your cards out
the door
we don't we don't have any power you
know
okay let's just sorry
i'm sorry sorry dude
can we go to a financial sanction
or would that be something that members
would consider
because
if they're elected we can't we don't
have the power to save
the best
way around that would be to have
suspension
forget the financial bit because
the financial bit probably doesn't
affect
and also but only if that person can be
represented by another cancer or
whatever
they're suspended because you've got to
give the voters some representation
and that's the very nice problem who
said
if an officer
transgresses yes
you can't do that for the cancer because
the effects of members that's the big
problem but if you suspend them and let
it be known
that this character is suspended in
theory
that should be sufficient
there are two levels of suspension short
if it helps it's just going to come back
with the government's response to um
suspension because one of the
recommendations from the report was that
suspension should be allowed provided
you've got the independent person um has
been consulted and and and
agrees with that
and they've said um there is no
provision in the current legislation for
a sanction to suspend a counsellor found
to bridge the code of conduct and this
was a deliberate policy decision by the
coalition government at the time of the
localism act 2011
um
they felt that and the previous
standards regime had failed and that um
many complaints that came through about
counsellors were
vexatious um politically motivated and
that it affected free speech um and for
that reason they weren't um
keen on bringing back suspension of
counsellors and i guess i can see that
from both sides
you know i you know and i think actually
one of the points that we're coming on
to later is you know as a counsellor
what problems have you had you know rise
um and i think there's a big thing in
the press at the moment isn't there
about um counsellors um being abused
either on the street obviously we've had
the um
very serious assault cases
um and via social media
um and i guess
it is
um
a problem because you can be subject to
i think anyone in public life
um is subject to vexatious complaints at
some point so it really is a balancing
exercise between
um
between evidence i can see it from both
sides i i think the difficulty that
you've got
i guess the government's not expecting
behavior to be so appalling that you
have to kind of be thinking of
these sanctions
i hope they listen to the lga
sure and when we had um inquiry at the
beginning of the year
into a member's conduct she felt after
actually reached the time that we didn't
need anything else about what was more
sustainable to us
[Music]
well
i think that sort of winds the
conversation up there and
do we want to give some strength
to the lga and support them in going
forward to look
at
the strongest sanctions
a lack of faith
in the councillors
could
help could actually be responsible
enough to make such decisions
so they've sort of let it down
i would suggest that
if you are keen to actually have more
sanctions
to uh legal officer
to look into
whether
any representations there because we are
a little bit behind the tanks turn scale
a lot of i think the
consultation along with this last
quarter
so
i think
it can be it is the view of the
committee they wish to have more you
should register it and then it's on file
should we get a chance to um
visit any consultation which may come
with
changes to the government
[Music]
we did respond to the initial
consultation this is the
outcome right that um
feeding
back
so there really isn't another level we
can go up to really on this one
the lga is still going to lobby
but i
agree with councillor james and that
they've just
done an in-depth consultation and
in-depth
report so i'm guessing the
chances of changing the regime now
probably quite slim
but that doesn't mean it's impossible or
it doesn't mean they won't i i guess
it's a little bit like turkey's phone
for christmas in a way
um so
yeah
we are where we are at the minute we're
really
i think
i think it's time we do some training
there the item seven
today um what the
and whether um some members have gotten
into other meetings to attend which is
absolutely
um fine so i thought today
what we're going to do is going forward
um i'm going to try and break this down
into um bite-sized chunks because i
i know that
from a
member's perspective and even from an
officer perspective to have someone sat
here um talking at you for hours on end
um
has a propensity to make people switch
off so
today um
really to design the training going
forward what i thought i might do is try
and make it a little bit interactive
and check it out to members in the room
to have a discussion about
what difficulties you've faced um since
you've been elected um
i know if that's through um making
decisions from members of the public of
any of you had
um
unpleasant exchanges
and then we can kind of design the
training um
to
what
members kind of
want it directed to so
i'm gonna check it back to members
festival just to um ask
what difficulties have you had since
being elected because we although it's
not an easy job
i am the minute i was made a counsellor
i had lots of people coming up and
asking me questions and i didn't have a
period of answer
your bang right in there the minute
you're made a counsellor they think you
know everything and i don't i still
i think don't situation for a counsellor
has been made much worse by
facebook for example yeah where
you can go on to i suspect any um
community
put in that position
in all areas um the standards licensing
planning and all of that so this is
really
a refresher
that i have special
knowledge
i mean anyone can attend all committee
meetings
[Music]
whereas
when it comes to
how the b8 is
two different things so are we
[Music]
is to talk about
why we have a have a code of conduct
behavior on what you know
all of it but but how to be a counselor
really does feed into
the code of conduct and the code of
conduct that we
have effectively sets out
the lowland principles
for anyone
[Music]
so anyone else want a lectured
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes
so when you're saying
i don't know how to be a counsellor
you follow all of those principles and
that's what our code of conduct is
effectively made up of everyone each
authority might have slightly different
kinds of conduct
um but they are all based on the seven
nolan principles
how you be a counsellor in between that
is entirely up to you when everyone's
gonna have their own different styles of
how they want to do things how they
conduct things um
but as long as you're following those
basic principles which imply you
it's just
ordinary decent behavior
and being careful in relation to
interests knowing what our interests are
and if we've got an interest or a
conflict of interest in relation to any
matter that's been discussed in my view
there isn't
you can't go far wrong provided you're
following all of those um you know we've
got 36
members
you're all different
you all do things different ways there's
no right or wrong way with it
effectively
[Music]
he said somebody will be interested in
only housing others will be interested
in planning
your own tech then
that's the cancer
it is not easy to start with
the training
helps no end but of course it takes
weeks
it doesn't help you
it's experiencing yes it's knowing what
to say what to say
[Music]
[Music]
because the minute i become a counselor
[Music]
[Music]
i will say when the trainings roll down
in in
the may after the election we do put
other
training on
um intermittently throughout the course
of four years one problem that we have
is is getting people to attend for a
start
um and two we're very conscious that
when
the elections first happened we don't
want to bombard
with loads of information because
you know i know myself if i'm sat there
being spoken to for hours and hours on
end
i have a propensity to switch off but
i'm also more of a practical person so
i'm doing i learn by doing rather than
sitting there being quoted at and so we
do we do do try our best i mean there's
some committees for example where
you need specific training such as
planning and licensing
um but in answer to your question if you
follow those you can't go far wrong
um
any other
problems
that you've been encountered
i have to say
that in my three years i've not had
any problems
i've been really fortunate and the fact
that i've
i've made a lot of changes in my life
and
[Music]
i'm still respected by my nine parishes
[Music]
unfortunately
social media is
[Music]
[Music]
it is very
frustrating but you must surprise these
people that just feel that they're all
here
i think i think it's probably too much
as i think of this
or in each case i've answered fully
and acknowledged through experience and
it just shut them up completely
both instances but in a
semi-main direction
and that's all it's about
[Music]
because
only this week i saw on
[Music]
an active member of this council
is it for that chancellor to receive
those directory marks to take down him
or is it something he should report
[Music]
um effectively what happens is i take
the complaint as a monster one percent
review it it then goes to that member
for consideration and then the
independent person the only um
difficulty will be reported is we won't
be able to
and then you know usually we can resolve
these things informally so it's very
pleased to say it's very
rare that we have an actual
standards hearing i think we've had
two since we've been at storage so
on social media is that something
is
[Music]
to
um
[Music]
[Music]
so you have yeah and that's the role of
the independent person they are
independent to
the investigation
they're independent
from
college and they're there to give that
outside view
and actually the independent people are
there for you to be able to
as officers
you can approach us and we'll always um
give advice um on any situation
um but you have we've got three
independent people louie's sat there now
their contact details are available
so they are
someone that you can bounce ideas off
and have that back check and then there
is a real um
fine balance between
free speech
putting your opinion
[Music]
[Music]
it might be an idea to
say to new counselors but
before you put anything on facebook
think
am i saying the right things here how
would i feel if i received this email
with it more anger
another required
is it really necessary do i have to
respond to this and have i give them the
right information across
and it's a very difficult thing to do
because
you put on facebook it can be read by
hundreds whatever
you're bound to offend somebody
somewhere on the way
so if you're going to offend somebody
make sure it's a very small effect
something very large and you're not
likely to get a damage
yes the other thing i think to be very
careful about is that if you're
putting on a post
it's your opinion yes it is not that
not representing
some posts that i see so pretty close
[Music]
you are in difficult you know difficult
situations as counselors because
there's always whatever you do there's
always going to be a group of people
that
disagree
um
but at the end of the day you are
elected to represent
and elected to make those decisions on
behalf of your lecturer
and some of your electorate won't always
like those decisions some will and i
think that that's a
but if you're putting your political
opinion on or you're
that's not
planned or definition i think it's when
you go a bit further and start naming
people you know
and that's that that's always the the
dangerous territory but i'm not i agree
it's not an easy
kind of situation um to be in
um just look forward to that
and then go again
um
so
this is
the reason we have the nolan pencils
this is the reason that we have um
the
code of conduct essentially um
transparency
um
people
voting them on behalf of the electorate
they've got to have people have got to
have um faith in your decisions and
confidence i think that probably goes
back to the point that you're making
earlier counsel harry in relation to the
dbs checks you know i
tend to totally agree
um
wish we could kind of enforce that but
um and and we expect everyone to act
with dignity effectively and that that
you know i i in some respects maybe it's
a shame that it's necessary to have over
conduct because it's
in my view obvious that you should speak
to people with respect i mean everyone's
gonna have a difference of opinion
that's democracy if you don't like it
you know you don't want something you
need to miss it um you can challenge
people but you can challenge people in a
respectful way
okay
so what do you think are the main
challenges
maintaining standards
[Music]
you defuse the situation
then
then remember
there's always
that is how when you
entrenched in your own i mean we all do
it and we have have eternal vision but
it's about being able to open your mind
to
other arguments and
this is one of the thing i've had most
difficult when i first became a
counselor was i've just been a private
person
with a business
and my decisions were always right in my
eyes
come on
i couldn't understand it i wanted to
shout it
no you're wrong this is the way it's got
to be and that's what you've got to
learn as a counselor is
seeing the other
and then
improve you it does because it warms
your view
don't have to consult anybody else and
when you
are in a council um you have to
um negotiate and persuade people to your
way of thinking and even if you think
you're right
it may make you another way so i suppose
that can be frustrating i guess as well
challenges
i suppose
tremendous is trying to be independent
regardless of their political
affiliation
the perception of the public is if
i think that can
i've not found it
yeah i mean i'm reading that
money
most
[Music]
is
sometimes
[Music]
a question
they don't respect you whatever you say
to them
then the politics often comes in
um because you belong to this
that's the way you think
so much
yeah
sometimes i feel
a similar position i mean i think judy
said earlier that you're just sometimes
bombarded and inundated and i think
members of the public expect you to know
everything that's going on at the
council when and all those decisions but
i guess the advice that i
kind of follow myself
and it's probably similar to you
is you you can't be expected to know
everything all the time
actually i don't know that
i'll go and go and find out i mean i i
have many you know approaches from
councillors asking me and different
questions in relation to different
service areas i've got quite a few
service areas underneath me but i i'm
not in the operational detail one day
today so for example housing i have lots
of questions about housing or particular
cases i'm not dealing with the
particular cases on the ground so even
i'm saying i don't know but i'll come
back and find out but like we have a
similar um difficulty we are expected to
know everything that is going on within
our teams and what approaches have been
made and when and it's not possible you
have teams of people and there's no
point if i was in the operational detail
and knowing everything all the time
having a team of people so
it's okay to say well i don't know
i'll find out um
movements so
sorry
i think it would be good um
uh to be
for counselors to be able to go into
bbc
to reach department
out
and i used to just go in and i was like
you know a little mold and i used to
just ask where do i go to get this
answer like you were saying i was so
good stop that but i actually i wasn't
shown around any you know
you know
any department or anything i wouldn't
know where you you know where you are
yeah
that's really interesting and so think
of it from uh from a
um cancer perspective and then that but
that's something that we can certainly
look into like you have yeah it's been a
difficult couple of years and even
i will say that the day we've recruited
um quite a lot of pre-k beard and there
was a time that i would go through each
other to know everybody but i'm i'm
thinking now as i'm
an employee you're kind of like looking
to see if there's a badge and a name
because you don't want to be
and yeah
[Music]
for example
[Music]
uh
out
i don't
[Music]
[Music]
interested on is there any specific
carriers that you think might be about
focusing on the training with your
interests
specifically i don't wanna
run through
um
and the other thing that i just wanted
to discuss with members is the model
code of conduct and then report it to
standards before chair but
um
it's effectively
um
it's similar to ours there's nothing in
it that um
arcade one that doesn't have and i think
that's why we discussed previously
probably not updating but what it does
do is give explanations which i think
would be
handy
and helpful and from my perspective
and the more um authorities that adopt
the model code the easier because the
easier it is because otherwise you go to
different local authorities and
everyone's kind of working from a
different
different model
all be it all
in principles but it's
but i mean this model code has been
thought through
a great length a lot of contribution
going into it and so could we put it on
the next agenda yeah
um
because we've got 64
towns and parishes within our district
and if everybody's working from the same
um code of conduct it would
say i've got this way over you know sage
them but it's it's easier if there is
one code and then i know that a lot of
our district members are also um
you know town and parish um
representatives or members of those
councils as well so it might be easier
from having different codes of conduct
um
whether we want to kind of maybe even
make expectations if there is no
rush i do think we should have a
nature
next agenda
and
in terms of training is there any
things that people can be involved in
something that they specifically like to
because we're going to do it in bite
size
chance um
yep
[Music]
um
[Music]
we've had that but
how would you
when you go in i think when you go in
and you do your decoration with the
ceo
and become
physically become a counselor i think it
would be nice then
if you're going in i don't know groups
of three or four and then
a senior officer
literally takes you around
i'll hold your hand if you like but
takes you round and says right
this department where tom and kirsty and
you know
democratic service just does this you
know
even
where your clay comes from you know
hr
because they do other things i've been
about
obviously over the last 12 months
governors in hr have different
photographs
and update my
profile
you know
but
you know all right i'm we're in year
three now and so i know you know where
everything is
you know and there's so many moves
because
you know it would be really nice
that you go around
and then it's done you haven't got to
keep coming back and saying oh where do
i find jenny where do i find someone you
know where they are
you know
and you can get on and do your job
i mean if you've never been a counselor
like me
you know
you've come in five out of a gun and
you've arrived
you know you you're clueless really i
mean i didn't know that i didn't know
they're working i didn't even know how
that torridge worked i didn't have a
clue i mean nobody asked me questions
for the other side you know i remember
my first parish council meetings and
they said and now we get a report from
the district councils you might be
talking have i supposed to have made a
report
you know
yeah
yeah i mean to be honest we haven't got
a clue overwatch
the guys that have been
counselors but
eight ten twelve years it's great
they know through the same emotions
i know but it would be nice
you know
to have that
start a kickoff if you like so you've
got i mean you've got
the basics of
each department so if you go to a parish
council meeting somebody says oh i've
got a planning application
oh
in the morning or email that department
or you can pop in if you know them
put it in right
now
you know
you know they're just it's just helpful
for the next the next month i mean you
know may will be here in a minute
you know and then you'll have a whole
big bunch of idiots like us standing in
front of you and we want to give them
the heads up
but not all of us are going to get
re-elected or we some of us can't even
stand i don't know
you know
i mean it's the nature of the beast yeah
yeah i do feel jews just unlucky with
the code
[Music]
yeah i mean when we started being dude
it was john walters yeah just come in if
you don't want to go just
you're just going to see john and he'd
be the punk of all knowledge well now
it's tom
you know or sometimes you go to the
guild because they
that's part of their role is to give you
that support point you in the right
direction
um i mean obviously
i would certainly take away what you're
saying and trump was not in his head
because
i mean tom's working on that new
induction process so we can certainly um
look at that but yeah if in doubt um go
to the demo services team and they will
point you um
because i'll give thomas out
you've got your own things
okay
[Music]
right so um
at this point um
i'm going to have to say goodbye to any
members watching on youtube
part two
which is uh private section of the
meeting thank you
so much